good morning mr. president
I'm deeply grateful for your welcome in
the name of the all Americans as the son
of an immigrant family I'm happy to be a
guest in this country which was built I
look forward to this days of encounter
and dialogue in which I hope to listen
to and share many of the hopes and
dreams of the American people during my
visit I will have the honor of
addressing Congress where I hope as a
brother of this country to offer words
of encouragement to those called to
guide the nation's political future in
fidelity to its founding principles it
I will also travel to Philadelphia for
the eighth world meeting of families to
celebrate and support the institutions
of marriage and the family at this
critical moment in the history of our
civilization
mr. president
together with they are fearow citizens
American Catholics are committed to
building a society which is truly
tolerant at inclusive to safeguarding
the rights of individuals and
communities and to rejecting every form
of injustice discrimination with
countless other people of goodwill they
are likewise concerned that efforts to
build adjust and vastly older society
respect their deepest concerns and the
right religious liberty that freedom
reminds one of America's most precious
possessions and as my brothers the
United States bishops have reminded us
all are called to be vigilant precisely
as good citizens to preserve and defend
that freedom from everything that would
threaten for compromise
mr. president and find it encouraging
that you are proposing an initiative for
reducing air pollution attention
accepting the urgency it seems clear to
me also that climate change is a problem
we can no longer be left to a future
generation when it comes to the care of
our common home we are living at a
critical moment of history we still have
time to make the change needed to bring
about sustainable and integral
development for we know that things can
change such change demands on our part a
serious and responsible recognition not
only of the kind of the world we may be
giving to our children but also to the
millions of people living under a system
which has overlooked them our common
home has been part of this growth of the
excluded which cries out to heaven and
which today powerfully strikes our homes
our cities our societies to use a
telling face of the Reverend Martin
Luther King we can say that we have
defaulted on a promissory note and now
is the time to reach
we know by faith that the Creator does
not abandon us his never forsakes his
loving plan or repents of having created
us humanity has the ability to auto
error in building our common home as
Christians inspired by the Saturday we
wish to commit ourselves to the
conscious our responsible care of our
common home mr. president the efforts
which were recently made to mend broken
relationships and to open new doors to
cooperation within our human family
represent positive steps around the path
of reconciliation justice and freedom I
would like all men and women of God will
in this great nation to support the
efforts of the international community
to protect the vulnerable
you know in our world and those stimuli
in the
and inclusive models of development so
so our brothers sisters everywhere may
know the blessings of peace and
prosperity which God wills for all his
children mr. president once again I
thank you for your welcome and flow and
I look forward to these days your
country god bless america